hello welcome to about the games ball
plays the final game spot plays on this
floor so we decided to do it on the
lobby said Rob handler is nice it's an
honor a pretty good game came at games
of command 2015 and this is one of the
last ones Just Cause 3 even playing it
you play a bunch over the weekend and
last week let's jump right in oh yeah
what's gonna happen right here what's
gonna happen right here Danny is a you
know I earlier I just hijack this
helicopter looking a little bit worse
for wear yeah you know the there are
some Sam's service of air missile
establishments around these bases so
they do some damage but right now we are
going to show you the some of the newer
features so right off the back walks
yeah you know I love like grapples like
in between his legs like so he's got the
grapple he can do with the hell he wants
with it yeah this is rico rodriguez the
famed recover same yeah so you can just
this is your your mounting position on
any vehicle okay is it like idling is it
like just saying in the same place yeah
we'll do that what not for very long but
turbo yeah but uh screw this helicopter
let's ask a deer alright so the new
thing is you're obviously of your
parachute and then you got your new wing
suit which is an absolute blast so you
use this this is obviously faster but of
course you unlike the parachute which
you can basically tether and pull every
anywhere and everywhere yeah this one is
mainly just for like altitude and speed
oriented so you're not using this as
much if you didn't want to like dive on
can you glide in it pretty effectively
or is that mostly parish you can get
pretty far but if like it's when you're
going uphill that the wingsuit
eventually kind of becomes your tongue
yeah and you hit the ground and it's not
fun look at this weird time it's got
like skyscrapers and then this little
like little quarter up on the top that's
kind of looks a bit a little bit older
yeah actually think that's like one of
the mill part military I can output side
also Harry yeah I think so but um yeah
this is I think one of the biggest
cities in this game is a game big just
goes through it's pretty big yeah it
feels pretty big I put 20 hours in and I
haven't seen I've only seen about half
can actually look here so this is you
start right here and yeah I you know I
liberated all this stuff lose you and
redder than red is that ok so uh I'd say
this you know this is roughly half but I
think cool um I haven't done I've only
got a few missions
as far as the story goes and stories all
right yeah this I'm like surprisingly
i've done 20 hours of just liberating
and it doesn't get old it's so fun
that's crazy yeah Mike's review he did
say that there the story stuff is
probably the weakest stuff in the game
but it's it's funny that you were able
to do that much liberating and 20 hours
worth without really having to care that
much about some of the story stuff yeah
absolutely get ignore it a little bit
look at this so those people I want to
show some new things off we're in a
Mediterranean right um exactly right
yeah it's like some fake-ass ibiza or
New Yorker or something these people
these guys will start there so uh one of
my favorite things yes wrong is you get
these booster mines which I have
upgraded and the upgrade system is
actually pretty cool so I want to show
you all this so here's your My Mind's
now you start off and you can turn these
off and on which is great so it's kind
of or it's not just like a basic like
linear one-way progression system you go
back and you can turn these off so right
now like it's there just mines but then
I put on these and other booster engines
so they've got Rockets coming at it
right and here are things I've you want
lock these two challenges this one's
called like a crash bomb they're
scattered across the map and you upgrade
with gears but there's things you'd want
off like for instance proximity trigger
will will go off only fan enemies nearby
right so if I just want to use these
boosters the way they are I want that
off I definitely want this off which is
like safety so it's like it won't it
won't detonate if I'm above it right
you're near which is weird and I mean so
that's if your explode but if you're
wanting to do all that crazy stuff we
are triggering it on the people and
vehicles you want that stuff off exactly
for instance watch me do stuff like this
go dark well I know you might as well
give his lady one as long yeah it's a
party all right Alexis ever playing on
pc right now yeah pc i got a little bit
just give it a sec oh you know what I
forgot it was kind of a weird thing when
they get in this like kind of scared
mode they won't do anything it's like
the animation doesn't let them get all
physics eat yeah exactly you gotta do to
someone who's like calm down a little
bit exactly so let's try word time and
also so of course you get the oh no all
these poor people this is crust oh shoot
you got to stick it on his butt Rob I'm
did I heard you said before that they
kind of they react and say like Rico
stop and think yeah they'll be like come
on Rico come on man this is no funny dad
wait uh no ideas should be able
sometimes this vehicle oh that's right
I'll be okay oh hey go so you can just
you can strengthen the mind Sakai now
lives inside that building gave your
games 2015 a little bit buggy I hurt
Mike's a in the review as well uh yeah
it's like you'll have like issues with
like the parachute um which will okay
this should work cackles yeah so why
you're gonna leave him go so I let go I
did lb and now the parachutes gone okay
and now he's fine he's oh thanks oh cool
place a falling apart oh that's good
sweet bro you know it's funny only oh
that's good Oh see sometimes it's great
when they get a little air explode
eventually oh god yeah ship shown that
but yeah that's basically that uh so you
have a lot of fun huh you got the
graphic as we get a bit of frame right
here you got the graphics are pretty
high yeah they're pretty high right here
we can turn
haha new have a high was the performer
bin actually fine fine this is different
computer so I haven't like optimize it
as well as I thought I was I mean it's
been off and on for me it's been pretty
good all around so maybe turn in
settings a little bit I've heard there's
some stories coming at people saying
they're have a little bit problems
everyone yeah just check out what the
office all right now so people can kind
of see maybe turn in the honest honest
tropic down or something this is a big
one alright so what you gonna do this
car okay so this is key so you do this
it's all about having that the higher
tether and i miss to secure it good
enough oh nice this one the ball wit he
says yes I don't know how other people's
let's plays at this game will then be
shooting people but you've got you cut
to the core no just cause experience
it's just you sticking mines on your
goddamn vehicle oh yeah and that what
I've also figured out it's like so you
can eventually unlock like six mines hmm
I have like four now the thing is is
that good thing they presented present
yourself the thing is that some the more
Minds you have the more erratic it'll
get writer like you want like only one
line and I've also unlocked like you
know in each one of these like you get
like stronger tethers more of them these
are stronger mines longer boost power
more powerful so you eventually realize
uh you know there they become a little
too powerful right so you just need
level one maybe early on you want like
my car back over great you know it look
it's still a good good day so what do
you do at your rocket said oh I know
what I'm okay all right who do you want
I got know that they'll do this guy
right here this guy he's doing something
what's he doing car doesn't have its
emergency brake on he's just he's a
cartographer he's just doing some good
dog raphy he must be lost let me help
you out maybe stick some of those people
keys take more people on yeah
actually yeah let's get a feel like
[ __ ] rubbernecking you should not be
watching this come on not cool see ya Oh
are they gonna try to run away good
trailer you can just stick him back onto
the car oh just Skippy oh you got a lot
got away this time oh yeah so cool so
that's you know that's some of that um
let's let me show you off another cool
feature so this was supposedly I didn't
play much of two I played all of one but
true you know and it goes with each
other to know these guys Square Enix
like realize like uh you know the tether
is awesome let's exploit that another
thing that mods were popular so you
could like you know do like console
commands like that and just like you
know drop in a vehicle driver going on
so you do that now again you can
unfortunately you get these things that
are called like beacons so you get a
certain amount and I have you know
obviously I can upgrade and get more
beacons so I can do something like this
where show some of the cars yeah yeah
cars oh this one actually will get kick
of this uh this cars so dope Senate Oh
crop it's like a Formula One car or
something oh yeah it sounds great ah so
yeah weapons sniper rifles have you got
the beacons in the beacons um they from
I've been noticing they just come off
the bat they just like show up like
every life but you can you go to supply
points and get beacons and you get also
true travel flares in order to like
essentially a pass travel back yeah so
can I throw this guy okay and then after
wall kana now it shows that haha that
quick Jesus everything in there once
yeah [ __ ] comet is on prime baby yeah
you [ __ ] ticket tape with a confetti
and stuff like a look at this nonsense
it's like a it's like a like a Ferrari I
guess sir yeah taking the piss out I'll
dude this poor aha rigo driguez is not
my car come back give you my car back
which is correct
wheels are still spinning and damaging
this f1 car is like killing me this is
like no it's such a beauty there you go
oh you had it you had it hey I got to be
pretty delicate sometimes but yet I mean
this is great so you know like I've been
doing a lot of fun stuff words like art
here's an outpost we attach this to a
helicopter and get inland and section
like its just oh so like different ways
of attacking yeah i'll post as well I
saw you strap a tank to a helicopter
yeah and then drop the tank from midair
and then jump ahead of the helicopter
into the tank and then that was protect
all right yeah it was really hard to do
so then later on also like you'll get
like stronger helicopters are such [ __ ]
here's actually a perfect geotech a base
is early anywhere around here you can
attack um we'd have to get an airplane
but this is a great it's guys out of gas
Sue's guys out of gas so we I've
realizes like what's not which I mean
one way of doing is like our I'll attach
it to my car but then of course I like
brought my car the gas station and the
car went through or past me and blew up
the gonzo so the easiest way to do this
is uh I'm gonna bring him down oh then
you do something like this you could
stay there at the whole way and canter
failed innocent hurt did it really well
I haven't done that fart killed him you
killed him who you do this already this
you just just bring it you just bring it
these people are just watching like [ __ ]
man Rico is just the worst all right so
what we got here are your back you're on
an airfield somewhere yeah this is a
airfield that I have liberated come
stocked with like an f4u Corsair but
they call it something different it'll
look at the possible get us passes when
you know it so this guy is legit I've
found this to be like one of most
successful ways to liberate a base mmm
is you show up in one of these guys may
be bomb the ever-loving but Jesus I've
it babe unlimited bombs and rockets oh
yeah it's like scale doesn't give a [ __ ]
if it was a kippah [ __ ] yeah and he
it's funny is you know I'm all for
realism I like the idea of like all
right yeah like maybe I'll go back to
the runway and refill Miami know if that
if that was the case this game would not
be what it is like they're just like nah
dude stay there and just destroy
everything so this dude rock on yeah so
let's blow the bejesus out of it all
right I like I was giving it like a
pendant you had a UI for your car to get
there and you're just like no yeah but
how it's up on top of that mountain oh
yeah beautiful they had to vista
unlimited it's just tough free big shoot
everything are you gonna make a good
first pass on this oh yeah God pretty
game as well must be said it is it is a
very pretty game yeah some air brake oh
yeah this isn't this a base it looks
like just a town yeah it's gonna bomb it
well I wanted to show you me running
into a statue with the plane because I
could do that pretty well it's not
probably that deal thing is just to blow
up to 1,200 bomb we got some heat man oh
yeah look at the statute bring it yeah
so do you have to knock over the statues
yeah so you deliberate a town and face
you kind of have all the same things
like yeah you got it so this is the
prison right here if you got a bomb the
prison you gotta release kill all the
prisoners well no you release them which
is kind of weird it's like I'm a rebel
but it's like I don't know what these
prisoners have done like some of them
are probably be prisoners of war but
someone who probably top [ __ ] idiot i
have bad dude ladies exactly but now I
let them all out [ __ ] it start the
rebellion free but everyone's house
keeps getting robbed exactly yeah
alright so I'm you know
next on the agenda actually I I'm so
scared when you get at me I wish I
always get scared but know if there's
there's like a boundary oh my god this
is terrifying I might screw up the Jets
haha but it's just worth did good by
Ashley site I'll do this so watch BAM
I'll turn these things off so now they
want to switch them off so now there's
gonna be just mines this is good alright
so I'm trying to run this to do a statue
I don't want to boost your minds take
effect yeah okay you're missing episode
of all right here we go la pression air
Rob it's the final gamespot plays on the
third floor well now there's pressure
good okay can you see him see that guy
is it the same statute every time yeah
oh it's over there to right it's the
where the way point is yeah there you go
left
you got it all right like I said yeah
yeah I guess that town wasn't liberated
let's call it terrific just cause 3
experience Rob Hardy thanks for putting
up all those three videos on gamespot
and people can check him out on the site
that's right for more hot Just Cause
action and if you're looking to pick up
just cause you're interested in this
game or you're a little bit disappointed
with some of the performance stuff let
us know the comment box below we'll be
back we'll assume what more gave us up
plays not sure where it'll be won't be
here somewhere might just be our voices
for a while but jazz stay tuned to
gamespot com for more those see you next
time
you